um
your favorite rapper sugar free now if
anyone who's like heard you or listen to
your raps like
it's very evident that he is an
influence it's crazy i was i was telling
him i'm like
you know especially being from out here
when people hear you they'd be like oh
you sound like
like i used to take when i was first
taking label meters they was telling me
like man you sound like the crosby team
between kendrick and schoolboy q and
you know i get it but i always tell
people like if you really know like
if you really know you know what it is
that's sugar free reincarnated
yeah that's i mean the first time i
heard you like on uh
instagram or twitter or whatever it was
i was like yo he's i hear the sugar free
influence like heavily you know what i'm
saying um
and i know that you know you just posted
a video of you guys in the studio
together i believe you played me a song
where he's on it yeah
um how big of a deal is that like
you know bigger than signing a deal
that's crazy man so it kind of give us
that
that story i literally just posted the
video right now we in the studio and he
telling me about how he [ __ ] with my
style and i'm like [ __ ] i took your [ __ ]
right and just made it my own like i
literally tell them like it's like
having a space gym ball like i just
went to you and i'm like i can't take
your power but it's like i just took
you know your cadences yeah and flipped
it because i mean i ain't no pimp i
ain't i've never
you know right right right before but i
[ __ ] with you know
his message him his message being the
fact that all right this is what i'm
gonna talk about
this is what i'm gonna be on and i don't
give a [ __ ] about nothing else but
this you know i mean you ain't never
heard sugar free disney
nobody you ain't never heard him talk
bad about nobody on records he was like
i dedicated my career to this and i
[ __ ] with that
you know and then just the way that he
did it it was just yeah his delivery i
feel like you know we don't
give enough props to sugar free when it
comes to like how unique of a artist he
was
it's very charismatic real
conversational you know like
and nobody sounded like sugar free ever
no you know like if you think about like
his era there was nobody who you could
be like
like you could box him in with right
right right and it's so crazy
one of one you hear certain people that
got the influence like i was in the
studio in one take jay and i was just
and i was uh listening to him like i was
telling the homies i'm like damn me and
want to take jay
rap the same way like we just do it
different
mm-hmm but we both took his cadences
like when i was really listening to like
a song you did i was like damn he raps
the same way i would because what it is
is it's a swing
so we're not rapping directly on the one
you know you might be slightly before it
or slightly after
you're talking to free about that it's
like certain people you hear that
so they might say oh you sound offbeat
but it's not really you know of b and
that's like why
blast beats are so smooth because
the drums are hitting different so if
you would nod your head like this to a
certain song
now you this way because it's just a
slightly different brew
yeah i do that with the wraps but not
like sugar-free [ __ ] man i met him a
couple years ago
i had popped up at this uh at this spot
he was performing at
wiggle my way backstage or whatever and
you know introduce
myself and it was just letting them know
what he meant to me i got cool with one
of um
one of his artists pomona dirt shout out
pomona dirt
but um we stayed kind of tapped in on
the ground so
they were doing something else i popped
up there pomona dirt took me uh
to the little backstage area so i got to
uh you know chop it with fred again but
that was like
2018. i hadn't physically seen him
um since so it was crazy because when he
got to the studio
like you know i got these dark ass
shades all right right i had these shits
on in the booth and i was recording with
my eyes closed i look up
in this [ __ ] then walked into
the booth and i'm like oh
[ __ ] you know nobody even told me you
know that he was like there at the time
so i come out there and he was like man
i've been looking for you
i've been looking for you for like two
three years i'm like goddamn like i
would never think that
right you know so he remembered you for
meeting me backstage yeah but he was
like
i wanted to sign you he was operating he
was like i've been looking for you
that [ __ ] told me so i've been
looking for you in the daytime with a
flashlight man
am i lying john